I can talk about your name yeah what's
up guys
happy weekly Tuesday reset I told you
guys yesterday that the maintenance
might wear until 12:00 turns out bungees
like hey we finished early so good for
us they finished around like 10:30 I
think fun fact John Luke's almost done
updating so once he gets done there
we'll go into it but dead orbit dead
over it one you're not that excited what
a scrub I want to know how many of you
scrubs in the choker that's kind of mean
how many chat people in chat aren't dead
orbit I want to drink your salty tears
your sweet tears
I thought future war cult was actually
gonna win because there was that like
weird glitch about that yeah that you
could just keep turning in engrams past
34 more than just shaders and I was like
oh dude that sucks everyone's just gonna
keep turning in because why wouldn't you
right so I thought for sure a future
work hall would win they didn't maybe
not of people were aware of it to amuse
it maybe that could be true actually I
thought they weren't gonna win but uh
once I logged in it was like hey dead
over one yes
what's up a host sign I think that's how
I say your name and everyone else in
chat were live every day at 11:00
usually Tuesdays at least for the last
couple weeks has been destiny to reset
day I'd like to keep it that way but you
know obviously you guys will be the
people helping control that but uh I
would show you the gay but you know I'm
gonna hijack this and turn into a star -
Valley Stream oh gosh who are you the
marrakesh 2.0 of GameSpot right now see
how that goes you know Joey split okay I
got you
so he's so I could just kind of swap all
that I be awkward because then we'd be
going diagonal uh-huh Gabe Maji f WC
future work halt for the color fu space
emos yeah that's that's true Michael
mello dead orbit that's right
we did it we did it we did it for the
arc Iraq July
we love you guys oh thank you
that's really kind of you hopefully
Aaron gets into I just told me he'd be
update two which is like whoops it's
weird because I had my playstation on
you're in rest mode or at least on yeah
and then no it was like on on and it
never asked me for like an update or
anything so I'm just like I know I could
have tried a foursome whoa
Kenny Kenny my man man you want to keep
alive actually I will say anymore the
monarchy probably had the best looking
armor of the three actually looks pretty
good too but dead or I don't know
something about dead orbit [ __ ] I guess
destiny had if you want a hot cup at
gameplay we have a God in the expert
gameplay that was second possibly bring
it up well we like stall for time here
sorry that's taken for this copying is
taking for I know let me see if I could
pull up his this is a destiny stream but
we're gonna pull up some god tier Cup
edge stuff I guess dude Joey so good I
was playing this game I'm scared though
remember last time I was like messing
around with this and it like oh yeah
John Luke seems a little low I'm always
that I talk I mean I can quieter I could
try and like talk better goop size is
always that Mike I don't think it's that
Mike I think it's me that is a
consistent thing I've noticed is that I
always talk much quieter than everyone
else
alright well I boosted you up okay that
I don't know if that's gonna help but I
do I dare to try to add something here
and hope that it doesn't break it's too
early no really fine someone explain why
so much it like dead orbit I don't know
I like that or because I think I'd just
like the color black so it's like
like that's really why I don't know
although right now I'm liking my my
current radar more like the purple gold
white kind of vibe is pretty that's true
the the but what she would call it's
good I would like to go to the gameplay
almost like PlayStation in hook John
Luke up and here I'll show you I'll just
show you that's where we're at right now
we're updating surprise destiny 2 pcs
out on the 28th so like in 25 more days
Peter Stormare hype yeah that's dead
orbit voice actor is that Pierce whoa
that's also why people picked dead or
gone that I would have picked dead orbit
because Pierce remains the man okay well
there you go
no idea changes everything changes
everything
well you chose poorly this time but
maybe next time I could play some come
on no I can't actually I've it on PC you
never mind cut the cuphead now I don't
even hear we're not we can't play it I
can only cut to cuphead a video of
cuphead alright let's go start that up
start it up alright so if you guys
didn't know weekly reset nightfall is
Sabbath ons song it's kind of a long one
it's got the anomaly modifier we got to
shoot those thingies and then it'll has
the new one called momentum where you
have to run around to get your
regenerate your health you don't
regenerate otherwise what's up Kalinin
Callum Anderson how are you doing and
then what else is there there's a you
know flashpoint is on EDC so we're
rotating planets here
yeah FWC if I had the best garden snake
13 and why why but he says dead orbit
shader on active FWC guns perfect yep I
have a lot of orbit shaders unlike stuff
that you know isn't of the right faction
but whatever cubes asking if we tried
cuphead yeah liking it a lot but one I
am not as good as Joey so you'll never
see me play it here but then I'm playing
it exclusively co-op with my girlfriend
we're both having a really fun time
but as Peter talked about his review
co-op is actually kind of a hindrance oh
really
especially in the bosses are actually
fine for the most part but the the
platforming stages were clearly not
designed for co-op and they yeah so I've
heard mixed things about the co-op like
I heard it's like like fine but then
I've also heard that like because you
have another bug head right it's a mug
head bug heads on the screen that person
is also shooting which then just all
just adds more to the chaos that it
already is it's the fact that on the
platforming stage is the camera the
camera has to adjust normally your
characters on the center of the screen
put the camera at all times but when
you're playing co-op the camera has to
adjust for both people so you'll have
situations where if one care if you get
ahead of somebody else yeah then the
camera doesn't adjust for you and then
you'll have enemies like come off screen
oh okay got it guys pretty much the
solution it's like we have to be
constantly moving at the same spot at
the same time which we're pretty good at
doing but it's still just like we feel
like we're fighting against the game
like there's a point where we were both
like look I think if either of us were
just playing this level by ourselves
we would have already beaten yeah the
fact that we're playing it together
feels like we're not beating it mm-hmm
and that that's like it shouldn't be
that way got it which kind of sucks but
we don't want it like we want to play
together and we have a fun time playing
it together a great game hosting or ho
sign we rated forts uh we did it
yesterday me and Miguel so if you want
to check that out that stream is
archived and voted so you can check that
out I believe the forts us motorsport
seven review will hit today some point
I'm not sure exactly when oh that's loud
that's because I have different
headphones like yeah alright I plugged
it into my controller alright here we go
this is a kind of long one alright so we
have 14 minutes that's not a lot of time
okay this one's kind of cool but it's
kind of long
or the boss been kind of annoying yeah
the boss is kind of annoying
and I'm guessing we don't have a warlock
which kind of helps the the whole
momentum thing because you could just
healing rifts but it's uh we don't have
that so we'll see how it goes
I feel like every week we do these
dreams it usually takes us to two goes
last week we beat it in like 20 seconds
which is obviously nice but this week
you won't be phasing in and out which is
awesome I'm gonna shoot some anomalies
also 100 no over here is it happening
yeah it happens to me too that's why I
turn off notifications but I needed it
so I could accept your friend request
but you could have just joined me from
the clan roster okay there's a lot of
stuff in this room that we got to kill
and also someone saying my mic is low
I've turned them up quite a bit me I
will try and project yeah just project
like one hey everyone else going I will
also try to adjust the mics for next
time which is apparently it's just a
trend that's happening I do not have
solar to get solar to get rid of that
that's fine I didn't really give you
much time to really deal with this so I
the shield's off by the way just be
careful again cuz yeah I'm already
eating it I will run around like a
alright there are anomalies in here yeah
they are sweet I see it there one more
in here somewhere I don't know where
though should probably just go you got a
hack the door or you shoot that I'll
hack the door good job good job
oh there's a lot of stuff that's gonna
spawn from like near this door area so
just be mindful yeah you could peek
around for anomalies while we okay yeah
there's a lot of a sneaky spots in here
where it looks like it's like yeah you
know like a thing but then it's like
just like blue light and it's kind of
like garbage hello
dangle it up let's be a wizard or some
sort it's good oh nice
so what try our best to look at chat
yeah but at the same time it's gonna be
a little rough
obviously we'll do our best what do we
get says Michael v4 dead or be winning
you get to actually buy the scout rifle
which is pretty awesome I also didn't
realize that you weren't gonna be able
to buy the other weapons I thought that
they're gonna like let you buy them for
50,000 but that is not the case you can
only buy oh god there's a lot of stuff
at the door the other door at the front
door where we came from and cursed at
all and the nights are pretty nasty so
let's be careful of that took down I'll
take off the shields and let you guys
finish them off I got an article these
are real pesky okay oh you guys are both
dead sweet well this is a good
opportunity to shut the load out I
thought that was a push to walk I can
get rid of the shield yeah
where did he go all right he's a crap
oh okay I got cursed at all while trying
to shoot that guy yeah is it
Boyd burn no there's no burns this week
it's just that you're gonna want
different types of elements there's a
lot of the nights are really annoying
and their arc so I would suggest
bringing some arc weapons oh you're good
I will I will do the shield burning we
gotta go though okay we gotta go yeah
there's a good opportunity to oh wait
they did not open the door you should
watch out
good grenade and all right let him run
into the grains all right here we go Oh
watch out right big big guy okay Oh
totally with with that Rocky
Oh hands down
get it yet almost
I'm gonna run around a little bit here
you get some life back cool getting that
rid of the shields here left side
shields down again really the right
shield that guy's also boy damn this
regens annoying rough it is to play the
field of view is is limited what that pc
life huh I need that no anomalies here
so let's just keep they were I looked up
a little bit I watched one video like
briefly but which makes it super
annoying but it says anomaly now inertia
is when you get the momentum I think
which then gives you life back oh wait
maybe not maybe you have to gain inertia
it doesn't get momentum I just know that
I just know that as you run you'll get
momentum which then okay like yes he
like I gain momentum which then gave me
a life back are we good looking around
there's one do you see one yeah nice
good work okay that's one those one
behind us okay I think there's one in
this next room to the left I think nope
maybe not this room man yeah everything
you were not reading huh I was in here
if you're curious I can show you so then
you can show them it's you know so cool
we're pretty much have like close to
them what did I say we started with like
13 or 12 is 14 minutes okay
so in this one we have to slam dunk
those things right well we got to kill
this witch oh you're getting the ping
yeah okay sure we're doing the killi
killi thing although I think I'm gonna I
might die doing it myself we'll see let
me slam dunk please nice there's another
anomaly you got one now I got one but
okay it is thanks oh nice
that's a tricky spot I'm still getting
it so there is a third one okay
yeah the tricky thing is like sometimes
like with the detection it's like not
like just in this room I feel like you
never know too many blue things all
right let's just I found one up here I
think there's one there that's top oh
and top left yeah I killed one then
they're still anomaly detected though
yeah oh there's one over here there's
one right behind us that way oh you see
that one yeah alright yeah well we just
got 90 seconds feels good I think
there's one behind that thing too
because very blue yeah there's one here
too did you activate that good it's so
saying it though Oh
switch it up I haven't tried risk runner
yet it's pretty good it uh dirt against
fallen because of like arc damage but I
don't think there's too much arc damage
in this one so it's probably not as good
it was really good last
family or a couple I feel like all the
nights we've been running across the
park damage yeah yeah like that one does
so I'm gonna use hard light though all
right I'm more used yeah yeah go for it
and I just ran out of ammo cool yeah
I'll try to get that back for you stuff
for that one night in the corner
I think Aaron trying to sort them right
now so we got to shoot these shorts
I'll show you guys maybe it's in the
next room watch out there's an open whoa
yeah right oh I see yep I see a couple
anomalies cool awesome you take care of
that as we've been doing alright we'll
try to take down mister over here put
down a short barricade
his face and I don't and that night is
super annoying
it takes like a couple seconds to get
your life back so Swee mindful of that
oh boy oh boy
oh this is a bad idea you down yeah I
know that's Aaron I'm just running away
because I was trying to super and then
just a lot of stuff a lot of stuff out
there we need to kill the ogre yeah
which is almost okay check it made if
you can get Aaron that'd be all I'll try
to distract thanks grenade oh good
what is inertia I believe inertia the
way it works is like when you're not
moving you have the inertia right but
then once you start moving it'll gain
momentum and then you'll gain your life
back in it should say momentum okay
watch out there's two nights here
another ogre I'm not seeing so hopefully
that's an explanation of inertia for you
guys is that yeah you'll have inertia
until you gain momentum well maybe
because you just switched weapons
oh boy shields off on that night okay
I'm gonna grab Aaron I got okay double
wizard here it's pretty wizard Annie
ones about to die nice work
all right keep going
there's anomaly zipang yeah I've been
looking at all right no worries
yeah you've been doing a pretty good job
of filling in ami so it's also really
good for the stream too so that they can
see where you're shooting whether I will
just proceed to we're good
just run back yeah just run back and get
some life I would try to get and right
now or die possibly no I just gave the
momentum but so what's the run yeah you
have to kind of like at least run in
like a circle
oh there's another auger is why that
rocket told him this okay Aaron's bone
soup burger I think he's crazy but
what's he got
he's super hanging the ogre in the
wizard which he just didn't killed still
anomalies I don't know if should we keep
going or keep looking here one of those
toss ups I want to look at man yeah
we're getting like we're like two room
or like one major room okay as in like
an anomaly
see a blue light Oh get on my way Aaron
can you get light smoke yeah that's why
I had to run that that was no joke that
damage and waiting to revive you well
class is Eric using I am using a Titan
I'm using a hunter we have double titan
hunter which is you know not the optimal
lineup but it's okay I would say try to
bring a warlock with you for this one
because of healing rift and how good
healing rift is alright apparently
somewhere this is another big room found
one over here I guess I'll just shoot it
I just get it I see it okay it's one of
those things for the stream you know
yeah let me grab take this guy shield
there are more as well keep an eye out
night shield is then that was a shitty
throw
that night solo
do some laps yep
you see any because it still says
detected up Aaron got one up top good
job Aaron
I'm gonna have to back off for singing
oh come on the shoulder charge isn't
part of the count it's part of my
momentum still anomalies detected
apparently
oh there's one up there wow that's
really hard to see there's like in the
white oh yeah I'm grabbing the ball what
do I need to go
Oh down there okay oh there's a lot of
curse they're all good luck to me John
Luke I believe in you I don't know if
it's in that room oh god there's a
knight in there oh boy yeah all right it
says it going there you know I really
wish anywhere else
oh there's an anomaly here though in
this corner don't mind me oh no oh
that's weird
I guess what the ball you don't get
trapped which guy guy drop the ball I
just dropped the ball and hope you shoot
him where is he
alright screw it yeah trying to like
save that but no that's fine
I mean I have a super again alright
let's keep going
Aaron's gonna sort on just good go by
him thingy oh wait did anyone kill that
one that was in the back corner and we
go check the anomaly Oh Aaron's a madman
does he have the orb okay that's cool
yeah okay so the orb is for the next
room yeah he's going in yeah I'll try to
distract the Shriekers while you run to
the middle okay okay they're shooting me
right now so you should be good
slamma-jamma BAM nice work grab an
errand there's an anomaly still there's
no more anomalies at least so far still
none one more oh go ahead thanks for
she'd alright there's some witches here
gonna wake them up from this no we're
not turning back anomaly detected though
oh I fell down I think there's no I
think there's so much yeah I was too
that's alright damn we'll find someone
earlier I take it back oh there's one
you see it oh yeah it's pretty obvious
that one
so it is like a little different blue
yeah but still it just like it's so much
easier to tell when it's not the same
color definitely yeah there's one ahead
of us right yeah see that blue I like it
when it's dark and then you know like
okay there's gotta be one there for sure
for sure did you get it already
no there's another one right no I can't
see oh oh maybe it's not Oh No
okay apparently that was this Angry
that's super weird I don't know Oh
crystals anomaly detectives and keep an
eye out
oh please one oh nice oh man you know
what but the light was shining through
the wall so I was on the other side was
on the other side well played well at
least at least a show oh there's one
over here two on the left side Oh curse
they're all sitting here all right we're
at the last boss it's everything to have
minutes I feel pretty confident all
right
shooting the shard alright Shriekers and
wake up
with the rocket business right now seven
minutes I feel pretty good about this
yeah I feel pretty good this kind of
gets dicey though because a lot of stuff
starts to spawn but what does these are
super isn't it and we'll be good yeah
exactly
so far so good though I think well then
you got a dunk it at one point mm-hmm
it's a really good spot oh I'm on fire
now as I say really good spot on fire oh
there's a lot of ads over there
I will try to get rid of that night
shield if I can shield down oh I'm gonna
super try to clear some ads
oh I took his shield down
all right the Shrieker is now available
at the damage not anymore
teleported again he is middle it's not
good I'll go grab Aaron okay
all right I just got to watch out
there's like stuff coming your way
as much cover on this left side I guess
now
you teleported left-side yep what do you
got over there
where are you guys gonna get over you
five minutes we're okay I got my super
here that's good an hour thing where I
should wait I think it's fine I think
we're okay
I just know yeah I haven't done this
boss that much I think we're gonna have
to slam at some point though that should
be coming up soon yeah when we get home
to that oh there's an ogre now though Oh
what the heck did the ogre game life
what I think so it was like yeah unless
there's another ogre but how much maybe
there's two because I definitely saw
that yeah there's two ogres actually
there's another one oh yeah he's almost
dead he's back
Sabbath on he's gone I don't know where
I'm going to help back where to go
middle
Oh oh boy that was real bad he gave me
that he gave me the big the big balls
yeah me too and I yeah it's not so great
it's okay though plenty of time what
scout rifle that is what is that
nameless midnight though it is nope does
not compute Oh Aaron revived us or
revived me and he died I'll be back in
two okay so you're almost oh god I'm
taking a big damage okay okay it's funny
though the regen is like coming back
like fast enough so it's like
counteracting boss that's angry okay I
think just gotta clear some of these ads
that we can actually be damage on the
boss alright this slam dunk time slam
you got it I don't know where we got to
kill the wizard that's protecting the
ball right I'm gonna grab Aaron here in
a second
nope you second alright sorry we're just
gonna have another real close call you
know like last week
okay cool yeah I was like sure I'm gonna
go try to go yeah all right I'm gonna go
help Aaron I swam it to you though yep
toes all the way up there great there's
two wizards oh please Oh God sucked yeah
the ball is up there or it was up there
I don't know if it is yeah I jump I
tried to do it like right over it yeah
well we need like Aaron or someone to
shoot him while we I don't even think he
should come revive me because I have
three seconds oh the balls back where
it's at okay I'm gonna go grab it again
and try it I'm gonna just keep
distracting the wizards if you can
oh I was so close this is really not
good
we're not gonna make it I think we're
okay we'll see
depends can you get Aaron up I was
literally like right now hissing okay
the ball is still up there right of
course it comes back as I'm about to go
all right go for it
slam dunking
you got 20 seconds man okay well DPS a
crap out of it I think we're gonna get
that sounds about right
you know that's how we do it here last
minute what is life without destiny
that's a good question sparking kill the
Wizards yeah we're trying to sync it to
Kira we we're trying to and the problem
is I know you know what I should use a
coin that won't give us more sorry I
don't get one oh yeah it's just random
all right that's cool we got it at least
they got two stuck to the timeline today
oh we're good someone said embarrassing
I think these people haven't seen our
our last minute we actually don't make
it no problem not a problem there at the
end but not bad well that's my harlot
stir yeah it's okay I think hard lights
okay in the smaller areas all right cool
so I guess now we can just go do some
some flashpoint stuff on a on Eid easy
the earth yeah cuz you know I always a
lot time in case we fail in time and
then like another run but you know
lately we've been we've been scum
bagging it but but you know good thing
we shot enough anomalies good job
finding the anomaly no that worked out
we can go to the winding Cove I'd uh I
did the double double spam now do it
solo prestige no abilities that's that's
asking it too much I think we'll pass on
prestige if we can only do it with 10
seconds left I don't think we're gonna
be able to do prestige I'll just be whoa
I accept the truth good grenade launcher
there including grenades no I'm good
I got a unlucky sidearm which is not so
great
for obvious reasons
it is nice getting random 300 blues
though yeah well for me I've been using
a lot of um I'm getting like like to
like yeah like yeah 89 blues and then
I'm getting like 98 Legendary's which is
good because I think if I max if I try
and max my power level I can get to like
96 97 nice
Thursday a chess chair if you want
something so yeah we're just going to do
some public events now I think to kind
of wind down the stream a little bit
hear that where it's at also because
it's good for clan XP your weekly clan
XP and also for flashpoint which is this
week is on Eid easy on the Eid easy so
yeah pick up one of these we'll just do
patrols - got to be max efficient
yeah but that was not dad I guess you
know if I didn't know I didn't screw up
the ball thing like twice we would have
been a lot better better weapon set was
that I think I've had a better weapon
set picked out yeah I didn't really tell
you guys what to go I guess no one
seemed to have like a good range void
which was for the wizard yeah sense yeah
you definitely want to have like at
least one or two people at the arc for
the Knights and then like maybe one
person with void I did have a rocket
launcher but I saved some of the Rockets
for the boss it ended a rocket was kind
of helping out yeah I saw some Rockets
going I was like come on we could do it
someone said changed the hood the hood
from the monarchy actually looked really
cool did you get that at all it looked
really cool and you mark it I haven't
gotten a yeah I think our things here
the red one the red one is nice I like
the hood piece as well what's up
Mackenzie Walsh how're you doing see the
thing too is like I've done like a
couple of prestige nice balls but it's
like the incentive isn't I don't know
it's not as high for me right now just
because it's like you get an aura which
is cool because you know I really
empower knows you did something cool but
you don't really get any bonuses that I
know oh it's a gerund dropped oh yeah
he's all the way at the at the skip it
one token yep
here I'll pop a token so that we can
maybe get a better chance at some some
lutes
wonder what the rate order is this week
I wonder if it's cycled back to week one
where it's like bathers oh man that's
the other thing I didn't what's up think
about was a giant bomb they even leave
yeah oceans to ban they finally beat the
raid well I didn't even think about the
fact that I was gonna reset yeah that's
why they were doing it I don't think
they would have done it yeah probably
not
I'm surprised they even stuck around as
long as they did because I think Ben
pack and I think he said Jason a striker
was here until like I mean I'll be
honest I would have lost some of my
patience by then what's up salt that
Salman Khan I think I got that right
hopefully sorry the text is a little
small yeah
Salman Khan nice do you see the ship
pressure hello we haven't had enough you
got a time
hey there oh I see it yeah yeah Oh
circling or maybe it's not know that's
the point that's is that the other
ship-like a Rando yeah it kind of just
they all blend in left
hey you got a Brian Graham Paul's great
we're so good like two good feel like
they're gonna hurt them Jerry is oh yeah
I got some Rockets were my rock is
really slow he comes back around he's
like yeah and literally oh I got him I
got him
yeah smashing these guys new boss oh he
punted me
you punted me again oh that's probably
their new thing Oh God uh no that dog is
usually here oh yeah he's really
annoying okay yeah you just go there or
maybe the the big dude kill there now
the dog dog named cozy there's another
dog right here that's why
yeah bosses in the back he's pretty low
I will come Reza
ow
someone's asking about what token you're
using to get better it's the one that
you can use at the bright Ingram all
right yeah
I forget the name like Vanguard token er
it's uh pretty good name of it I can
look it up in a second once we finish
this thing it just it just gives you a
chance
I believe it does help though especially
when you're doing a lot of public events
I would say you know you should try to
use them also really you get a decent
amount of right does it's called
fireteam medallion it's kind of like
what the new three of coins is in a way
but not exactly watch you're gonna gain
sonic well I got to I got at least yeah
I have color wine you know I just uh I
like how some of the colors pop more a
little bit like the people do that yeah
I'm going to what is that sorry you're
gonna have to fast travel
it's the gulch I never fought the yellow
bar war hounds in this event yeah
Kenneth Williams that war hound almost
comes every time the that event comes
yeah as SKU said its fireteam medallion
you know how are you we're doing alright
what's up X well X is V one sovereign I
think John legs doing pretty well it's a
good Tuesday we did the nightfall 10
seconds well nail-biter but we did it
which is what matters also you know it's
a little bit harder when we don't have
our third fire team member like
communicating with us so I'm when he did
a great job of finding anomalies and
killing stuff wow like not really like
listening to I'm sure he has the stream
open but there's delay so it's like yeah
you yeah except you were like glitching
and teleporting like right way worse
switch my auto rifle
this gun gets okay not yet you want a
bunch of people for this one yeah this
one's kind of annoying the vents oh this
one's maybe the most infuriating to do
if you are with people who clearly don't
know how to do it yes I agree
the other one that I've seen a lot of
that people have been kind of like
struggling with and don't realize is the
blights one where you have to kind of go
in and out of the little black orbs to
get a buck and like people are just not
they're just killing the smaller orbs
well I'm just like sitting there like
shooting it by myself
got to put a dead orbit shader in my
origin story aren't the servers down no
actually Patrick the server's came up a
little bit early actually around 10:30
where are we from we are from well he's
originally from Vermont right and I'm
originally from the Bay Area which is
where we're at right now people like to
call it it's not a thing people I mean
I've heard people say that but it's
actually get ready to shoot this top
which ever top one that is before last
year people really didn't like know much
about Vermont or anything and like I
would legit have some people be like oh
is that part of Canada or something like
oh yeah yeah but now like any time I'm
like I'm from Vermont oh do you know
Bernie Sanders oh that this guy's new
though actually it always is the guy
inside Oh Bernie
yeah people always reference Bernie now
I see it's like that's our new legacy
that's all you have it's all we have I'm
like yes I've met Bernie Sanders
Berni next thing yeah we got it okay
okay oh yeah so this guy is new I was
right I wasn't lying you guys
cash are someone saying it's a Texas
servers are still down
they shouldn't be closed your app and
reopen it and see if that helps you this
bottom was a real pain you ready for
this this gladiator would get out of my
way did you find it is it on your side
no I'm gonna die immediately
I died too Aaron please
all right bummer
that's a right I think so no cuz the
guys out already
yeah yeah that's for hang that sucks
such as the such is life
oh well you're right I mean this was the
gonna be the hardest one of the harder
ones oh okay well that was yeah I would
try closing and opening it took me a
little bit to get on though I did have
like the servers were saying that they
weren't available what like I threw
grenade as I was jumping backwards and I
just thinking right now where you at
we get him yeah we feel like someone was
saying that like they kind of like
stealth mini nerfs
the heroic public events on earth I
don't know if that's true or not though
I haven't been farming around here and
Nicky cowboy says there's is up now
let's go to the sludge dead orbit dead
orbit
later Salman I think I wonder if this is
the taken one or if it's the fallen one
we'll find out soon enough
I can't tell sometimes it could be the
fallen one too yes some spots you can
tell what exactly is going to be
somewhere ambiguous
I think you're gonna play the PC version
at all me hi someone I think forgot who
asked me that I think CJ fans I asked me
that yesterday and I was like yeah I'll
probably play it a little bit for work
but I don't know if I'm gonna play that
I just don't see myself reinvesting the
time to farm again and I actually at
least since I remember how I told you
that it feels weird for me on keep mouse
keyboard even though it shouldn't it's
just because I'm so used to playing on a
controller that a bunch of people of
friends who are gonna switch over to the
PC so I know at the very least I can
play with them and I don't know 100% if
he was gonna do it but my brother was
expressing interest in trying the game
on PC on PC he's never played anybody
gonna be a good amount of people that
try it if you can still get in the PC
version I will happily oh I thought
you're for sure like when we first
talked about this like you were for sure
you know but oh but this is more of a
motivating factor yeah yeah I'm never
gonna play the PC version but as far as
like having someone to play with that
kind of thing you are right in that I
mean I've hit a point in this game where
I'm just like oh you know I can't play
like once a week now yeah Dylan H yes
dead orbit did win Marc Marquez stone I
don't know how long you had to buy your
gun I think I want to say it's like a
week I think they're here for a week
also if you guys haven't seen it which
will show later is that there's um
there's more like dead orbit like banner
stuff now in the tower now that they
want will to kind of just signify that
they want also the weird thing is you
cannot buy the other weapons from the
other vendors even though like for
50,000 so you can only buy the dead
orbit gun assuming you had pledged
allegiance to the Dead orbits has Bungie
stated
see versions gonna have like the event
to run at the same time I yeah that's a
good question because Randy was trying
to ask me that yesterday and I was like
I have no idea I would get really
confusing if it's not right like if the
nightfall is different and things like
that try to time in yeah which means
like wouldn't theoretically when you get
the PC version right out of the gate the
raid would be that's another question
they're asking like as a raid its give a
label like the moment you start and then
like it doesn't matter or do you have a
week you know yeah it's a really weird
one but at the same time you could argue
it's taking one you could argue that
they don't have to follow the same
schedule because they're technically not
cross played and like they PC could just
live on its own but it would be weird
really weird especially with their
communication where they're like hey
guys this week factions are available I
also find it weird that like there
hasn't been any mention of like this
this month's calendar at all right which
they like showed you the whole first
month of like this is what's gonna
happen this is next week's nightfall you
know yeah so it's definitely weird
because we're pretty sure that like iron
banner will probably happen like this
month I think and so we'll like hard
mode rage I think yeah yeah so I don't
know we'll see because in my opinion I
rather they just kind of suck it up make
them uniform so the PC version initially
is a little bit weird where it's like it
has all these extra features in it you
know
from the guy watch out dudes coming yeah
I get what you're saying
that'll be weird for like a week but
then from then on everything's kind of
you know in parody to each other yeah
yeah I we had the the pikes it'll just
get even weirder when it's like DLC
stuff crack how do you you know I assume
those will launch at the same time right
like yeah
those are taken for the person asking
I'm gonna die trying to rock it this guy
there's too much I should really kill
ads Bob just says iron banners next week
where did you get that confirmation Bob
tell us heady to me do some iron banner
yeah iron banner next week if it if it's
happening yeah definitely we will be
doing some iron beignets
is he dead yet no he's not far from it I
like couldn't even see him for a while
you like the speared for me
he's in a stupid bubble
no I don't teleport away from my grenade
and go nice so many captains guess it's
a guess not a fact but it will happen
okay we got three blues I have a
question so clans are cross-platform
yeah but the client XP is still like the
group XP stuff is that still platform
based like our I guess I don't know yeah
I'm not sure plan on xbox are they are
they also contributing to our overall
right or do they cost for Chris Pereira
he swapped to Xbox he left us for some
other people okay only then that's a
good thing to ask
yeah I'm just kinda I'm just curious
like when I find when I go to PC I know
we can do before then in the stream we
could do one crucible match and
hopefully win as a team together
oh and get that other one for the plan
I'm at winding Coe back to that first
one because I'm just gonna kill this do
it
you do you
yeah so okay so Bob was a guest so I
can't say that it'll definitively be out
next week but I'm pretty sure October
though I just don't know when we shall
see
give me them free Ingram says GU yeah
all that hard work you're doing the
public events here Aaron will eventually
catch up Johnny if you're not being able
to login I would say you know just keep
trying I eventually got in officially
stated the iron banners in October but
no specific date confirm that's correct
Wow there's a lot of chests there's one
over there too oops
guys start it don't catch all later if
you're still on keep on keepin on thanks
naked cowboy thanks for tuning in enjoy
your reset day
assuming you're playing
yeah we gotta wait till the new this
week from Bungie as tech encaged
mentioned we'll find out soon enough I'm
sure I just would be shocked if there
isn't like iron banner like hardmode
announcement soon for october because
even i'm running out of stuff to do
right like other than getting my 102 305
like there's not much for me to do and
like collecting you know miscellaneous
raid weapons or something
have you gotten back into the raid since
or are you guys kind of just done with
that now that you've finished I did the
one time I am I have friends who still
do it every week so I think if I wanted
to do yeah I have to help Sherpa a group
on Thursday I just don't like to try
trials I haven't tried it yet okay it's
not too bad on certain days time the
ships here by the way
[Music]
I only got off one rock at that time
well
it's pretty far away for now I'll tell
you what it comes back is it back again
help you out
where's it at oh of course he like
didn't chase you the one time I shot a
rocket
he's like stuck out at night huh
got it it's dead yeah there's a big dude
here though
ah nope that didn't work
and the war dogs about me now big boss
is dead or doggy is still chasing me
we're honoured yeah six around it's a
high-value target Aaron just got him all
right good work necessary to finish that
nice exotic finish that first game
before you start playing the new one no
not at all they catch you up pretty
quickly the game also knows if you
played the first one
and it Gulch it'll make references a
non-story which is pretty pretty neat
that's the one thing I'm gonna be kind
of bummed about if I go to pcs you won't
have all that stuff I have a sentimental
attachment to my my hunter character I
think played with her for what four
years now hmm
so that'll be a little bit of a bummer I
can like recreate her but it's all good
to say it won't be the same
all right probably do one more public
event then would hop into PvP and
probably call it a day and hopefully we
can do a decent job couldn't even grab a
fourth person if we can find someone in
the clan I enjoy doing this is a nice
distraction good breathe air from your
history of yeah it's today's all script
reading so jeez okay the hard part yeah
it's always the worst part for me is
spreading the script and it's just a lot
of research a lot of writing which is
not my forte so it helps for me to have
like a breather yeah shoot some space
aliens space aliens yeah I would say if
for those that didn't don't know John
Luke and another one of our video
producers here Richard Lee they're
working on a history of like kind of
like a series essentially of breaking
down all the gate Wellman all the games
of one set game franchise franchise
although eventually maybe a branch onto
other weird categories but that kind of
stuff yeah it's a very broad topic you
can cover a lot of things so next one's
Lord of the Rings right oh it's just one
of the Rings games this is actually more
interesting that I was originally I was
initially kind of worried oh my god this
might be kind of dry but it's actually
more interesting than I was nice
originally thinking so I'm actually
pretty excited about it
yeah well check out his exotic as one of
the last things we do when we go to the
towers so I can show you guys that dead
or butuan etc etc wait the things up I'm
gonna be shooting this one once it shows
up
well I say yeah we got it
yeah you're pretty far away okay and
this awkward Sparrow spawn so yeah
that's the best if you guys didn't know
that instant sparrow is the only sparrow
you want I just don't like you get it
yeah I've only gotten one like you were
mentioning it and I was like I've been
living this life for a long time what do
you mean I didn't even realize it at
first like like once you pointed out was
like oh my throw does do that oh and
then I was instantly salty Oh what in
the crap gladiators are not messing did
you guys feel like I did not a good I'm
trying to clear something to add so we
don't get ravaged so like we did last
time oh there's a band of roving pikes
whatever
well you have the other high-value guy
here is almost dead I could just go
finish this ass off
not good dad I don't know I think so
look for a middle yep yeah yeah we got
it
get out there's air and being a man
killing the other high-value thanks
Aaron we went out the way he lived
yeah
there he is oh I got that uh Engram that
you get from our not Ingram the emblem
that you get from the killing the random
guys and the public events heard it's
like only specific to like when there's
like another dude
that you can kill you'll sometimes drop
the emblem yeah I feel this guy's yeah
on a pike oh he's dead
yeah I'm looking for this bottom one
which one is it mine all right on my way
no oh we gotta we gotta we gotta got it
worth worth 100% worth was not taking
any chances that I probably could done
with us hello pro game G welcome back
familiar name do you actually play again
G though no why oh oh there's a there's
a interceptor and yeah there's a lot of
stuff
Oh
Oh
this interceptor guys so annoying nope
damn there's Pike's there's interceptors
what is even going on where's si he's
again g-man duder I mean you kinda have
to be with the name way back that's fair
he's dead we should be dead yep yep nice
milestone nice it finish the flashpoint
all right let's go do that
mother-effing PvP for the clan exotic
probably not like you just gotten exotic
so you're probably knocking yeah yeah
there's there's like I would say there's
like a mini time where it kind of thing
out all right I'm gonna go send us a
quick play actually should we invite
someone else clan probably got to go to
the Orbitz maybe we can get a regular
day maybe we can get a regular Dave here
Dave Dave gee wit your boy your divinity
boy yes he needs healing you got it and
there are you still in the divinity
train yeah plane divinity great game oh
he's with somebody he's exploring will
get Peter Brown listen right Peter Brown
annoys you think do you think he's he's
in orbit team let's see if I can get
Peter Brown in here games right you're
my favorite youtubers thanks appreciate
it
oh man hello eighty eighty Walker do you
say a dad or eighty eighty are you an ad
that guy okay I say 80 82 is it one way
I want to say one ways correct and the
other is not yeah but then it gets into
like a weird like yeah I don't want to
get into that argue some people like
they've said it in different contexts
and rob has like a really funny story
about that where he was like getting
into like a thing with a guy about it
or something
scanning into a thing about it with a
guy I don't like a prosecutor just kind
of annoying not getting around by my
main ingredient let's see do we get him
nope
let's try fighting I mean with Aaron
we'll be fine
yeah I know I think technically just you
and me would be fine actually oh damn
the confidence i er let's just do it I
was just trying to get someone else in
just sit all I meant as far as the
reward goes yeah but we got a win though
it's true well we can also do that just
do me it's fine it's fine
all right gonna do PvP then we're gonna
go to the tower we're hopefully gonna
win PvP and then we're gonna add decrypt
John Luke's exotic hope you get
something good and then we would have
finished two of our four clan thingies
normally I would have got us the raid 1
tonight but uh well they'll have to wait
told them all I do appreciate how
consistently people have been getting
the raid and trials reward yeah someone
in our I don't know who in the clans
doing the trials one but thanks to them
I would assume I'm getting my groups
doing the raid yeah Barbara's been doing
it god bless cuz I can always just turn
on my finger I better walk to Hawthorne
yeah it's weird though they said like if
the 300 or whatever Ingram is was
supposedly a bug right the the raid one
and the trials they still haven't fixed
that so I don't know if that is the case
yeah so my friend was telling me it was
a bug but the fact that they haven't
fixed it makes me think like okay wasn't
actually not a bug and he was mistaken
or is it a bug but and they just thought
it actually maybe we should just keep
because this kind of makes sense because
I actually do get the logic behind it
yeah cuz it's like you get the benefit
but you're gonna actually have to infuse
you know yeah you didn't do it
all right we're playing control I like
control
what's up scarlet shadow are you yeah
we're going how long it takes to do the
PvP weekly that's good yeah it's like
half the time if you do really well on a
match
you can get like I think I've gotten 30%
before it was double that before I only
have this baby barricade that's not good
they're not coming through that way
that's for sure
BAM got two for one oh I got pulse
grenaded back so you're on your own good
luck hi he says hi and then bye okay bye
yeah all right we got B they took C so
I'll take C back Oh
Aaron's on the case I might blow up
dance with this guy all right
do bleh all right cool chicken see back
I'm coming back to be to help ya
hopefully there's not too much activity
I see one person coming from the far
side who's about to get flanked
Wow there's three coming your way maybe
four oh boy
yep nice oh oh you got worked with coils
in house Manor whoever saved my ass all
right we got B
they're taking see okay yeah see maybe
Savior defend be working out pretty well
so far my needs on there but it was too
late you got two guys coming to be from
see Aaron sick and a so I'm gonna come
to be to help you oh yeah yeah just
okay that's fine I have no good name
either which is bad got one got a dip
though this grenade is too much damage
the house man is here with this sword
though nice house man killed another guy
okay we got all three
five minutes plenty of time to fight I
got someone coming on me looks like a
couple
I'm coming to a I think we got both
heavies though you know me and the house
man triple yep let's try to get that
mercy on him - oh yeah coming to the
slam house no it'll kill him he's my
super
oh they all over it now we ready I'm
coming to you I'll let these guys grab a
back they're taking C but that's fine
are they actually on B yeah oh yeah get
the gun business no I got him but he got
me at the same time with what I was like
already kind of little oh that sucks it
sucks how I gonna get B because they
doubled up yeah alright that's fine
though weird all over the place right
now but we're massively ahead so kind of
doesn't matter
I can't let them have this that dude Oh
storm trance oh I tried a fusion rifle
the stormcaller what he did not die they
casted hammer esteem all right I'm gonna
take B while there I'm getting a contact
destiny servers it'll go away that's
been happening I feel like this always
makes me nervous okay where the hell are
they
I was getting a really weird thing last
welcome dude how come I can't take a
beat oh yeah it happened man we're about
to win that match why wait we might
reconnect back into it yeah we're back
in oh we're totally back in mmm
I hear it I hear it on my screen I don't
hear it on my screen nope are you like
out I don't know I'm like I don't know I
hear gunfire yeah you'll eventually come
back in tapes back in it's making it
happen that guy's dead
good shot all right let's do it in front
of him he's shooting him all right cool
oh he just are chartered I see that oh
he's about to die though where is he oh
they have all the zones because we
disconnected did they not just connect
that would they must not I'm gonna take
B we're so up by a lot though if we lose
because of that disconnect that is
garbage okay I trade it with the guy
that had power think as long as we hold
a it shouldn't matter for a bit get be
back to you in a second
very good
got nice nice back deseed life yeah it's
been happening more than I like it too
all right
capturing I should have knew those
problems when I was standing on being
like nothing was happening
not really yeah we got me back still not
a
you add me where is this dude go to oh
you got killed all right we got this
yeah it's not gonna matter
wonder if Aaron deceived he probably
didn't
oh wow there's like three here also got
exotic really nice so we should have got
the clan thing done there too crucible
boom here we go I'm just knocking out
all that stuff alright why don't you
take us it's alright to do it yeah I got
to do it my bed I saw the game wall
around from everyone yeah alright we are
going back to the tower to show you guys
that dead orbit win also see what John
Luke got from his exotic cuz that's the
most important to be honest nobody cares
about dead orbit winning probably other
than me like all Isana trolled me he
like he told me he's like oh yeah all
over neogaf they said future work halt
one I was so sad and then Bundy tweets
dead orbit winds like JM 76 we did with
10 seconds to spare yeah I got it was
actually really good
and then it got a little sloppy when I
couldn't slam-dunk the last ball I kind
of got a little hectic there but if we
were able to if I was able to slam dunk
the ball even the second time we would
have had a good minute or so like that
or we just have to really kill the
Wizards I guess I don't know right I
feel like you can get in there though to
slam dunk and I think it's probably more
worth it but I thought it was a October
28th level of gaming not in 11 days I
could be wrong 24th I was wrong because
right around all this stuff the death
the stuff the death toll from Stein SAS
Creed Mario so that's the thing is like
I imagined my brother my brother is
definitely gonna pick up Mario I know
he's a huge man so even if he picks up
destiny and PC he problem pick it up
right away
okay well shouldn't he play it before
other stuff get three days in before
everything else probably I'm thinking
I'm gonna try to run fine like yeah but
like monetarily he probably
working Mario maybe he'll get destiny
for Christmas planet gamers I never
played destiny well if you like FPS
games with some what kind of light
MMORPG elements because it's not really
an MMO I would say this is a pretty
solid game I like the game just for the
shooting mechanics and the feel and the
sound I do I do like the loop but I have
to appreciate the feel the weightiness
of when you like the trigger and like
firing and like I also just like the
feeling of getting headshots hopefully
one of your purples turns exotic - okay
not so much but what am I gonna get what
do you want not a dupe okay I got so
many dupes I got three tubes yesterday
good luck
that I do lucky raspberry I think I hope
it's not armor is next page nope every
way yeah that was right that's right you
had to right right cuz collection you
have it already
well damn well I can that's a higher
version you can infuse it can blow one
up oh how high is it 300 nice no you're
good you're gonna want to keep that on
yeah why don't you quickly I still don't
have those those the orpheum rigs I
heard it's pretty good yeah yeah if you
use the sweet little what do you call it
yeah the arrows quiver quiver yeah I
want you after you blow that up why
don't you just show the the flags and
how they change then maybe run the dead
orbit so there's the dead like there's a
there's that one and there's one more to
your left or other side down oh you
could turn in your nightfall stuff too
if you want yeah I don't know like the
frequency of exotics has definitely gone
up but I don't feel like exotics are as
special as they used to know they were
so that you know
the first first game exactly so I don't
know it's like a it's like what do you
what do you want you want to like less
frequency of exotic shops that then give
you something more special or do you
want more frequency of exotic shops and
then just stuff that's like minimally
better than Legendary's I mean some
exotics are really strong we're pretty
strong but some others not so much
so alright no exotic for you
unfortunately usually those have a
decent chance of giving you one exotic
but now you can see Jalal who will be
selling you a $50,000 weapon because you
weren't dead orbit and that's it haunted
earth
fun fact is you can't is it good I don't
know yeah I haven't tried it fun fact is
that is that you can't buy the other
weapons which is weird to me but I guess
that's a thing is this easier or worse
than last week like six one seven asks
is that I'm guessing you're talking
about the nightfall I think it's pretty
doable I think the the key is learning
where the anomalies are and I think John
Luke shot a good amount of them in our
run so if you're trying to find out
where some of that stuff is if you just
scrub back in the DVR on either the
GameSpot player or the YouTube player
you'll actually be able to see what we
did and how we shot stuff I don't know
when the elo update will be for trials
briars because right now it's connection
based so it's kind of weird so sometimes
you get really strong teams sometimes
you fight against really weak teams it's
definitely not currently like super
balanced but I think that's it yeah John
Luke yeah pretty good day that's fine
yeah pretty pretty good day pretty good
day we you got an exotic sadly dupe but
we got a couple Klan things done we
finished a nightfall with 10 seconds
every week seems to be like this real
close I really don't like I don't think
we got it I'm like just give it all your
God but thank you guys all for tuning in
we will be back tomorrow at 11 a.m. with
the lobby and we might even be doing
Battlefront to tomorrow I'm not sure
what time yet so just stay tuned for
that
the beta tomorrow either the morning
before the lobby or yeah then of course
we have more streams this week Thursday
and Friday I haven't picked the games
yet because I'm a terrible person to
maybe star do maybe I'll entertain ya
but yeah come back for that stuff come
back to GameSpot for more destiny 2
coverage we still do all the weekly
resets and we'll be you know obviously
live when iron banners around when the
raids up we got John Luke's history of
coming down the pipeline for Lord of the
Ring games I think we're gonna have some
more shadow war stuff potentially this
week as well and then the 4 to 7 review
should be today so stay tuned for all
that stuff and we really appreciate you
guys being here but until next time see
you guys later
you